so hello and welcome to another episode
of biographics it's just a mouse
someone's going to see that I might be
not a male look way it's the mouse to
scroll on my teleprompter don't worry
about it yes as mentioned this is
another episode of biographics with me
your interim host Carl Smallwood and
today we're talking about Francis Galton
the father of eugenics and the original
article this video is based on was by
Juan Arnoldo I hope I'm pronouncing that
correctly if I'm not um yeah let me in
the comments but definitely go check out
their links below and let's get to it I
should quote my own thing shouldn't that
all right let's rock now that you're a
lot less Rock that'll be my fish now
cool
Great Britain in the 19th century was a
hotbed for scientific and technological
innovations Scholars scientists
inventors and theorists of the age had
laid the foundations for many of the
wonders of the 20th century in the
Contemporary era not all these
inventions ideas were for the better
however even if conceived with the best
of intentions in mind they would pave
the waves from the worst Horrors that
will darken the Skies of Europe and
Beyond one such concept was defined at
the time as and I quote the science of
the Improvement of the race or the
science of improving Stark just just
saying that out loud makes me feel dirty
I feel so dirty saying that out loud
but I'll power through in both cases the
author of these definitions are
referring to the human race and human
stock the author of those quotes was
also the originator of a science whose
nefarious influences would impact
millions of innocent lines in Germany
the US and Sweden among countless other
countries this is the story of Sir
Francis golton the father of eugenics
on February 16 1822 the seventh child of
Banker Samuel cerseus Galton and Francis
Anna Violetta Darwin quite ironically
named I guess given his later
contributions to science Francis father
was Erasmus Darwin grandfather of
Charles Darwin Francis
okay so I guess it's not so much ironic
as just
a weird coincidence I know that history
sometimes has Francis showed great
promise for science from a very early
age his older siblings described him as
a child prodigy who could read at the
age of two memorize poetry at five and
could discuss the Iliad at six the
little Noir however do not fare as well
as expected in school perhaps bored by
the constraints of the traditional
education system you achieve little
success and cause numerous disciplining
issues at the age of 16 francis's
parents decided to remove him from
school he clearly showed not aptitude
for formal studies so in a perfectly
rational move they sent him off to
Birmingham to study medicine after two
years of inconclusive studies in
Birmingham in London Francis dropped
from Medical School a win for
generations of future patients and in
1840 he enrolled himself instead at
Trinity College Cambridge to study
mathematics during his first two years
at Cambridge Francis did what many
students they sell at drinking partying
and generally hanging out with their
mates either on a boat or hiking through
the countryside tell you now I did not
do much hiking in his third year Francis
Santa to give it a go you know studying
again very calm for students in Britain
you did put a significant effort into
preparing for his exams ranking second
best is the entire school but his mental
exhaustion combined with the
disappointment of not ranking first of
course Francis to experience a nervous
breakdown followed by depression as the
path of all gifted kids isn't it of like
just finally coming upside you know the
limit of what you can achieve and just
not being able to handle it Francis left
Cambridge with a poll degree which is
the lowest possible degree to achieve a
pass sir you maintain a love for
mathematics throughout his life but his
bout of depression may have pushed him
to choose fields in which there was very
little in the way of academic
competition such as statistics in the
immediate aftermath of his graduation
Francis resumed his medical studies
which were interrupted abruptly October
23 1844 on his father Samuel died
Francis would later study the traits
which are inherited by children from
their parents in this case Francis
inherited something very important a lot
of cash which he soon put to good use
[Music]
in golton's own words at the time he
felt much upset and craving for a
healthier life I mean plenty of money
and Spares how many times Francis
decided to pursue a healthier Life by
traveling to Africa and the Middle East
golton reached Egypt in the Autumn of
1845 running into two friends from
Cambridge heads with Barkley and
Montague Balter they are some Cambridge
ass Cambridge names right there Golden's
travels in Egypt and the Levant would
deserve an entire book of their own so
I'll just give you some highlights
golton and Friends traveled by boat and
by camel from Cairo to cartoon modern
day Sudan along the way Dalton parted
way of his two friends but replaced them
with a couple of monkeys then Francis
and his Simeon companions bought a
steamer to Lebanon and from there they
travel to Damascus Jaffa and Jerusalem
throughout his travels Goldson was at
serious risk of being injured or killed
several times for example one is raft
cap size in the River Jordan or when his
Caravan was attacked by Bandits at night
who luckily contended themselves with
just stealing some horses but not his
monkeys Galton returned to Britain in
November 1846 still craving for a
healthier life Francis spent 1847 and
1848 and much of 1849 hunting and
shooting then he learned about the
travels of one David Livingstone in
southern Africa she's finally to follow
in Explorer's footsteps after securing
an endorsement for the Royal
geographical Society golton sailed off
towards Cape Town in April 1850. again
one book would not be enough to cover
golson's Explorations in fact he wrote
two books about the tropical South
Africa published in 1852 and the Art of
travel in 1855. both Publications were
very successful the latter was repented
several times and the former earned
golden a medal in the Royal geographical
society and a fellowship of the Royal
Society Julius travels golton exploited
his mathematical skills the fullest for
example he used boiling point
thermometer readings to estimate the
height of mountains and then use the
lunar distance method to calculate the
accurate longitude and latitude of the
geographical landmarks he encountered we
also Applied Mathematics to the
measurements of human features this
approach would later form the basis of
the science of Biometrics another field
of study that goal to be credited with
originating he would later see the
characteristics of fingerprints and
their applications criminology but more
on this later as he journey through
southern Africa however golden was
interested in other areas of the human
body when he came across local women
with very large breasts apparently he
devised a method to estimate the size of
their chest by triangulating other
dimensions in their bodies
Francis Galton returned to Britain in
April 1852 preceded by a scientific
paper detailing the namibian language
travels despite the niche nature of the
publication golsan McCain something of a
celebrity in London feeling exhausted by
both the African Adventure and the
excessive attention golden escaped first
to Norway for a fishing trip and then to
Dover there on January 5th 1853 he met
Lou or Louise Jane Butler Francis was
smitten with Louis and initiated
courtship which eventually led to
marriage as golden wrote in his diary
left Dover in March engaged in April
Spirit rapping Mania married in August
he certainly had a knack for summaries
the two married on August 1st 1853 and
after a honeymoon in Switzerland Italy
they settled in Victoria Street London
the galtons would not have any children
of their own what Francis did leave an
enduring mark on the world through his
numerous scientific Endeavors across a
broad range of fields he played native
role in the governance the Royal Society
the Royal geographical society and the
British Association of the advancement
of science Galton also conducted and
published numerous important
investigations in meteorology being
credited with the discovery of the
anti-cyclone effect and the drafting of
the first weather map pursuing his
interest in Biometrics Golson also wrote
three monographs on the use of
fingerprints as a feature to identify
Unique Individuals a body of work which
greatly influenced the budding field of
criminology Golson also showed interest
in less conventional research for
example publishing an article for nature
in which he proved the best method to
cut cakes it could be preserved for up
to three days here is how you do it you
have to slice all the way through
diameter of the cake so you extract a
long thin rectangular slice then you
have to press the reduce but still
semicircular half of the cake together
this will seal in moisture and ensure
the cake remain fluffy and delightful
for up to three days golton's passions
however were mostly developed in numbers
measurements and statistics counting was
second nature to him you count on
everything everywhere well it's out
statistics and publishes findings for
example he developed a model to assess
the level of Engagement in scientific
meetings by measuring the frequency at
which delegates fidget lectures and
you've entered a counting device a small
pocket ticker which you used to come the
frequency of attractive women walking on
the Streets of London galton's night for
measurements informed studies on these
next passion heredity he tackled this
field in a quantitative manner an
approach which laid the foundations for
the science of biostatistics and later
eugenics
foreign
Charles Darwin's work the Origin of
Species golden sought to understand why
the human mental traits could be
inherited and if they could be
influenced by nature or artificial
selection to this end he performed a
statistical analysis on the biographical
dictionaries seeking to determine how
frequently talented people were related
to other noteworthy individuals you then
compared this frequency without eminent
people emerging from undistinguished
unknown backgrounds at the time his
studies were unique in their kind and
led him to draw the following
conclusions and I quote once again
talents and peculiarities of character
found in the children when they have
existed in either the parents to an
extent beyond all question greater than
the children of ordinary persons in
other words according to golton mental
characteristics were determine more by
heredity than environment more by Nature
than nurture Francis published his
findings in two articles Heritage talent
and character published in 1865 and her
editored genius in 1869. in the latter
article he surveyed 300 families of
noteworthy individuals claiming that 31
of them had a prominent father and 38
percent had a prominent song hmm I do
wonder how really rich families
ended up having prominent children I do
wonder how having all that money
resulted in the children ended up being
noteworthy and exceptional themselves
it must just be good genetics it can't
be accessed to anything else another
conclusion he drew is that social
distinction I.E the capability to
succeed in life depending mostly from
naturally inherited Talent
golton however admitted that even a
gifted individual needed some degree of
elbow grease to fully succeed stating
and I quote once again if a man
possesses great intellectual value he
has the desire to work and in the
capacity to work too I do not see how
such a man could be suppressed ah gotta
let me introduce you to something known
as the working class as he continued his
studies in heredity in 1872 golton
introduced the concept of stirps the
Latin word for roots he defined a stir
as a set of elements which transmit
characters from one generation to the
next and individual stir up therefore is
directly formed for a combination of
their parents sturts this belief led
golton to his next conclusion that the
human race could be improved and the
same way that breeders and Farmers
improve the stock of their farm animals
in his own words once again a 20th part
of the cost and pains were spent in
measures for the Improvement of the
human race that he spent the Improvement
of the breed of horses and cattle then
science could be able to produce a
galaxy of genius and I don't think I
need to like
explain why that's wrong
right according to this new Theory the
key to Improvement of humankind was not
about improving environmental conditions
for new generations no the solution was
selective breeding this was the basis of
eugenics to prove his theory on
inheritance patterns in 1877 goldtone
conducted a series of Investigations on
Sweet Peas seeking to determine if plant
size and quality were inherited along
the way he made an important Discovery
in the field of biostatistics he found
that regardless of the apparent strain
some of the child plants with the same
quality as the mum and dad P some were
much worse but the majority were a
little worse this concept was formalized
as regression towards the mean the
process by which a random variable
outside the norm eventually tends to
return to the norm now in theory this
finding should have realistically
invalidated galton's insights on
heredity if applied to humans this means
that regardless of how brilliant and
talented your parents are you're more
likely to go into an average jail
average Jane than becoming a Nobel Prize
winner well Galton ignored his own
conclusion and continued to insist that
good stock as a predictor of future
success in his next 7 work inquiries
into human faculty of 1883 golton first
introduced the term Eugenics composed in
the Greek words for good and growing in
inquiries heat defying Eugenics as and I
quote the science of improvement of the
race a science which dealt with and I
quote once again all the influences
likely to give the more gifted Racers a
greater chance prevailing over the less
good races
foreign
[Applause]
conceived too and I quote once more give
the more suitable races or strains of
blood a better chance at prevailing
speedily over the less suitable
according to Dominique Obert Marson
lecturer at Paris Descartes University
golden used the term race as a
substitute for nationality in the
specific case of these 1883 publication
he focused on the English race which he
divided to three social classes oh this
is gonna be fun first the desirables a
class encompassing the aristocracy and
Elites in general yes the desirables and
anyone seen what our King looks like
right now can we put a picture of King
Charles manners I'll just like no just
his fingers that looks to me like good
breeding stock then he had the middle
class there's not particularly gifted
but still considered productive for
society and then finally the
undesirables you know Joe schmoe right
here or the poorer classes you know the
people who actually do all of the work
goulton's view that poverty was
determined biologically because of
course to remove poverty and reorganize
English society he advocated using
artificial selection because natural
selection was ineffective on human
populations how ironic that he didn't
have a kid Francis Galton followed up
the publications of inquiries by
launching an initiative to gather
intergenerational data on humans in 1884
he founded the anthropometric laboratory
at the southern Kensington Science
Museum this essentially was a booth
equipped to measure height weight chest
width arm strength hearing and other
various variables this laboratory
eventually collected the measurements of
9337 individuals more precisely sets of
parents and children Galton was also
interested in measuring the intelligence
of his tests subject to prove whether
there was a causal relationship between
parents and children he acknowledged
however that intelligence was too
difficult to quantify and thus Focus
solely on physical characteristics
Golson published his data and findings
and three consecutive papers in 1885
1886 and then a two-year Gap to 1888. in
these works the statistician was able to
demonstrate that the distribution of
anthropometric variables such as height
followed the so-called normal law this
law dictates that approximately 68 of
data in a set Falls in one standard
deviation of the means 95 of the data
will follow in two standard deviations
of mean and 99.7 will be the three
standard deviations and there's a nice
little graph that I can see which sure
like put that in behind me so everyone
can see this graph that we're all going
to pretend to understand
look it's all very complicated and I'm
sure statisticians are mocking me in the
comments but this is how I see it the
majority of people are just average
except you you are exceptional if you're
watching this you've got good taste and
presumably a very large penis well done
as an exceptionally gifted audience
crane for knowledge you'll be happy to
also know that in his 1888 paper Galton
first introduced another key concept of
Statistics correlation I quote once
again two variable organs are said to be
correlated when the variation of one is
accompanied on the average by more or
less the variation of the other in the
same direction coagulation must be the
consequence of variations in the two
organ me partly due to common causes
I've not had enough coffee
[Music]
golton's writings inspired many to
pursue studies in hereditary Biometrics
and biostatistics with a field Rich gown
had the most attention was of course
Eugenics but with the help of his
disciple Carol Pearson between 1901 and
1908 Galton found the golton laboratory
for National Eugenics and the golden
Eugenics professorship as well as
journals biometrica and the Eugenics
review the latter in particular gained
many followers in Europe and the United
States but golton's greatest success
with the conference he presented at the
sociological Society of London in 1904
entitled simply Eugenics is definition
its goals and its aspirations an event
often quoted as the official birthday of
the Eugenics movement at the conference
well attended by notable doctors and
sociologists Galton advocated for
eugenics to become a scientific
discipline in its own right it was meant
to be taught at University to be
introduced as and I quote again into the
national Consciousness as a religion in
golton and Pearson's Vision the new
discipline would ensure that Humanity
will be represented by the fittest races
Eugenics should cooperate with nature to
ensure the Improvement of and I quote
human stock by regulating marriage and
procreation we should clarify that the
reforms proposed by Galton could be
categorized as
positive Eugenics if such a term is
possible to exist for example research
programs identify and treat hereditary
diseases or tax schemes encouraging
intelligent people to marry and
reproduce but as this discipline took
hold none of its followers appeared
interest in its darker side so-called
negative eugenics measures which
advocate for the eradication of the
unfit elements of society for example
via Mass sterilization programs you can
probably see where this one's going
Francis Galton was knighted in 1909
becoming Sir Francis and in 1910 he
received the prestigious Copley medal
from the Royal Society but this would be
his last Triumph on January 7th 1911 so
Francis golden drew his last breath in
hasselmere sorry he left behind a
manuscript for a utopian novel
discriminant a world where Society had
been greatly improved by Eugenics albeit
founded on the wrong premises he studies
have been driven by Good Intentions
unless you remember the working class I
suppose you could not have imagined how
the dark side of his science negative
eugenics would generate into dystopia
thank you
shortly after sir francis's death his
spiritual Heir cow Pearson continued to
organize congresses on Eugenics
attendance support by political and
intellectual leaders such as Winston
Churchill John Maynard Keynes G.B Shaw
H.G Wells Alexander Graham Bell and
Woodrow Wilson in the UK negative
eugenics measures were narrowly avoided
in 1912 the parliament debated a mental
deficiency bill which included an
amendment prohibiting marriage among
those deemed feeble-minded the amendment
was removed but the eugenic society
pressured the ministry of Hell to
consider making sterilization legal
these efforts climb out for the
publication of a paper title
sterilization of the unfit in April
1929. luckily the British government
resisted precious to enact such measures
negative eugenics however successfully
took hold in the U.S and Sweden 1922 the
Swedish government was the first to
create an Institute for racial biology
right that's not a horrifying concept or
term on which conducted Mass
sterilizations on mentally ill
individuals and later on women in
vulnerable social circumstance says the
program was shut down only in 1976 after
an estimated 60 000 people were forcibly
sterilized against their will as for the
U.S the American Eugenics Society
because of course that existed advocated
for the force stabilization of 10 of the
population mostly mental patients and
the poorest elements of society
especially African-American citizens
because yeah
never never change America the US
government conducted 60 000 for
sterilization for the scientific
Community successfully lobbied to close
the program in 1936. American
eugenicists would find fertile style for
their ideas though in Nazi era Germany
as early as July 1933 Adolf Hitler
enacted the law for the prevention of
the hereditarily diseased Offspring and
it's worth noting that this law was
inspired specifically about the success
of a similar scheme in California
documented by the American geneticist PB
PB popper now you're really gonna be
walking around with that name we're
thinking you're like Superior to all the
people like Papa now the Third Reich
enacted both positive and negative you
genocide why why
there's gonna be so many parts how close
in this one ah positive Eugenics
materialized as the leban's born program
which oversaw the forced breeding of
children of pure Aryan descent negative
measures resulted in the sterilization
of up to 375 000 individuals it could
also be argued that the wholesale
Massacre of millions of undesirables
perpetuated by the Nazi authorities of
essentially a Eugenics program on an
industrial almost unfathomable scale the
other great dictatorship of the time
Stalin Soviet Union was also swept by
enthusiasm for eugenics surprisingly
however the other big Mustachio murderer
of the 20th century was never a fan of
sterilizing and suppressing undesirables
as his country faced a demographic
crisis following World War One and the
Civil War Soviet scientists dedicate to
their resources to instead positive
Eugenics until Stalin decreed the
practice to be fascist science so I
guess you gotta give it to Stalin on
that one in the early 1930s dismantling
all related programs this concludes our
overview of the life works and Legacy of
Sir Francis golton and we realized we
were only able to regress towards the
norm when it comes to describing such
complex scientific concepts for a more
in-depth understanding of galton's life
and discoveries we encourage you to
check out the sources in the description
below if you missed anything I've got
anything wrong please keep us honest in
the comments citing additional sources
if possible and yeah thank you for
tuning in to this episode of biographics
as now said it starts the uh the article
this video is based on was by Arnaldo
theodrani I hope I pronounced that
correctly and I've been your host Carl
Smallwood this has been a very harrowing
um
recording time 38 minutes for myself I
might need to stand up and go for a walk
around because that is legitimate I feel
dirty just saying all those words out
loud and if you have enjoyed this video
and found it interesting if you know
Darkly so leave a like comment subscribe
all that good stuff follow us on social
media and as always have the day you
deserve
cheers